did you know that two out of every three
guys are going to experience some form
of male pattern ball just by the tide
they're 35 you probably do now because
it's true for me it was much earlier i
was 25 sad sad days i wish keeps been
around when i was younger because
advancements in science meant that there
are now treatments that can combat the
symptoms of hair loss and help you keep
the hair that you have look it's too
late for me my hair is not coming back
but you don't have to be like me you can
stop your hair loss early thanks to
keeps keeps offers generic versions of
the only two fda approved drugs treating
hair loss so you might have tried the
before but never at a price this slow
that's right if you were thinking this
is some sort of medicine it's going to
be expensive or you couldn't be more
wrong keep starts just ten dollars a
month how does it work well for one
thing no need to visit a doctor's office
just schedule a quick online consult and
a bit later discreet package will arrive
at your door and you can use it in the
privacy of your own home so if you're
noticing that you're losing your hair
that's one problem that's not gonna fix
itself do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com forward
slash biographics or click the link in
the description to receive 50 of your
first order and now today's video
a generation of haitians it was terra
incarnate a living version of baron
samudi the voodoo lore of cemeteries and
father of the dead backed by his child
stealing boogeyman the tonton makuti
presided over the land for 14 dark years
like some evil spirit made flesh but
despite his pretensions to the contrary
papadoc was no spirit no mystical figure
rather he was a man of flesh and blood
just like any other with one major
exception behind his kindly seeming face
and slight frame lay a soul so sadistic
so casually cruel that it would inflict
pain and misery upon millions as
president of haiti francois de valliere
oversaw a regime of beer unlike anything
the caribbean has ever seen under his
watch up to sixty thousand were murdered
thousands more were tortured or driven
from their homes or while the rest of
society plunged into soul-crushing
poverty in today's episode biographics
is investigating how a gentle seeming
doctor wound up becoming absolute ruler
of his country
and the nightmares he unleashed
[Music]
[Applause]
when francois duvalier was born in
haiti's capital of portugal prince on
april 14th 1907 there was nothing to
suggest it'd ever amount to anything
much less become
leader of his nation his family were
bitterly poor as members of hate his
creole speaking black majority tended to
be part of a vast underclass ruled by a
tiny french-speaking light-skinned elite
yet it wouldn't just be life on the
margins that came to define valier's
upbringing but also events because young
francois had been born just in time to
experience one of haiti's defining eras
the american occupation since achieving
independence from france in 1804
duvalier's nation had spent a century
being battered by forces both internal
and external within haiti itself there
had been corruption coups and
assassinations well from the outside
france had imposed a crippling debt on
its breakaway colony that sapped the
young nation even so as the end of the
19th century arrived there had been
signs that things were looking up after
many turbulent decades society was
stabilizing local culture was
flourishing and vast inequality aside
trade was picking up but then uncle sam
came knocking and everything immediately
went to hell this was the era of great
american interference in the caribbean
in 1905 the us had seized control of the
customs house of the dominican republics
the other nation sharing the island of
hispaniola with haiti so when haiti
began one of its regular slides towards
chaos washington was right there to make
things worse starting in 1911 a series
of revolutions and coups deposed seven
haitian presidents in four years
sparking american worries that haiti
would default on its debt in fact they
got so worried that in 1914 president
woodrow wilson ordered the seizure of
the nation's gold reserves transferring
them to new york but rather than calm
the chaos that robbery only exacerbated
it like to a crazy extreme on july 28
1915 the haitian president vilbran
guillaume sam was lynched by a furious
mob just hours later wilson ordered
marines and deported prince soon 5000
u.s soldiers had landed on haiti
establishing an occupation it was meant
to last until order was restored instead
the u.s presence would wind up dragging
on for 19 long years for francois de
valia that meant growing up in a city
and a nation brutalized by an occupying
force coming from a u.s that was going
through what's been called america's
nadir of race relations many of the
marines brought their racism with them
that meant things like the kay's
massacre when u.s soldiers opened fire
into a crowd of demonstrators killing 12
people it meant things like scores of
political dissidence being executed but
the americans attitudes also showed
themselves in more insidious yet equally
damaging ways a major one was the
elevation of the already rich
light-skinned elite into most positions
of power further widening the gap
between french speakers and the creole
majority another was the corvae system
which saw tens of thousands of black
haitians made to work as forced laborers
a state of affairs that saw perhaps 5
000 die from mistreatment in short the
americans took the poisonous divides
that already existed in haitian society
and stretched them until the bonds
holding the nation together simply
snapped so when francois de vallee steps
into politics in the near future
promising a haiti that is unashamedly
for the black creoles he's going to get
an extremely sympathetic hearing but all
of that for another chapter for now
we'll leave off with fdr pulling the
plug on the intervention in 1934 just as
devalier is graduating from the
university of haiti school of medicine
someone from a poor background
qualifying as a doctor must have felt
like a great achievement armed with his
new life d'valiere immediately began
working in hospitals but he soon began
consorting with a group of writers who'd
been radicalized by the long occupation
he'd come out convinced that a rigid
black nationalism was haiti's only way
forward and they shared another trait
too a deep interest in voodoo
as a religion that rose out of the slave
trade's force mingling of cultures
voodoo had long been an integral part of
haitian society while the city dwellers
including devalier tended to be
catholics out in the haitian countryside
voodoo was everywhere whole swathes of
the nation seeped in practices aliens of
the american occupiers perhaps that's
one of the reasons why davalier's circle
was so keen on it as the clearest signal
that haiti lived a distinct spiritual
life but devalier also had other reasons
for being interested in voodoo ones that
were far less spiritual and far more
practical jump forward to the early
1940s in the united states program to
try and eradicate yours in haiti a
disfiguring skin disease that mainly
affects children yours is one of those
nasty things like polio that the world
would be better without and while the
u.s eradication effort would fail
washington would damn well try
recruiting haitian doctors to go to
remote villages and administer shots
among their number was francois de
valier it was from these years of
traveling haiti's fields and scaling its
mountains armed with medicine that
papadoc got his nickname he was bringing
relief to long neglected areas but it
was also these years that showed him how
immersed in voodoo the black majority
were how important it was to their lives
and just as other aspiring dictators
might align themselves with powerful
christian or muslim figures d'valiere
began to cultivate ties with regional
ungans voodoo's male priests it seemed
benign at this point just a gentle
doctor making friends with religious
leaders as he tended their villages but
really devalier was laying the
groundwork for his next great step into
politics as the 1940s past papadoc
worked to raise his profile becoming the
head of the ante yours campaign and
director general of haiti's health
service in 1948 he finally got the
promotion he'd been dreaming of becoming
secretary of labor under president demar
says estine but if debarlier had assumed
his next step would be into the
presidential palace well fate was about
to send him tumbling back to the bottom
of the entire staircase in 1950
president estimae announced that he'd
grown rather fond of being in charge and
wouldn't be stepping down at the end of
his term to which the military replied
uh-uh not happening they overthrow him
and installed colonel paul e maglois
although black himself maglois was a
puppet of the light-skinned elites under
his watch haiti threw its arms open to
international tourists even as it all
but barred creoles from public life but
for devalier that meant expulsion from
haiti's corridors of power returning to
private practice almost as if his jump
into politics had never happened but now
he had had the faintest taste of power
there was no way devalier could go back
to being a mere doctor again instead he
became involved in the ante maglois
resistance years later this era would
become a key part of duvalier's myth a
source of romantic legends and funny
stories like how he evaded maglar's
goons by disguising himself as a woman
on a practical level though this period
also saw two very important moments the
first was the birth of papadoc's son
jean-claude de valier better known as
baby dog the second was the relationship
that he established with another
resistance leader clemor barbeau a
one-time school teacher turned full-time
sociopath barbo would later become key
to enforcing devalier's blood-soaked
rule but first they needed to get rid of
maglois fortunately mother nature was
about to lend a helping hurricane in the
fall of 1954 hurricane hazel came
crashing into haiti trailing devastation
rather than help the afflicted
communities magoir allowed his cronies
to siphon off the relief funds standard
practice for a corrupt regime but the
response was anything but standard
outraged the population turned on the
president although he managed to cling
to power until 1956 a wave of strikes
and protests eventually forced him to
flee the country what followed was a
dizzying series of six caretaker
administrations each one more chaotic
and shorter lived than the last
eventually though it became clear that
no caretaker was going to navigate
haitians out of this growing crisis that
an election was needed to install a
legitimate leader one who could restore
order to an ever more lawless country
and restore order the 1957 election
absolutely would but only at the cost of
something far dearer than stability
freedom
all his life papadoc was convinced the
number 22 was his lucky charm so when
the 1957 election was announced for
september 22nd he may have assumed he'd
therefore win if he did he was the only
one although divalia entered the
election a known quantity a former
politician who'd helped topple maglois
corruptocracy he was far from the
front-runner he was just too gentle the
sort of president you could picture
being overthrown by the girl scouts the
one issue that he did have strong
opinions on unashamed black nationalism
was also the exact sort of thing that
should cause all the elites to try and
discredit him as the campaign wore on
though it soon became clear that all
these handicaps might actually be
strengths take the good doctor's naivety
while it might have seemed like devilier
wouldn't make a strong leader that was
exactly what many wanted the military
for instance began to bag duvalier
apparently thinking they could use him
as a puppet the light-skinned elites too
looked at the slight perspecticled man
talking about making the economy run for
the black majority and basically went
that guy
threaded us
please not was it just haiti's powerful
who failed to see the dark heart of
francois de valier across haiti many
still remembered him as the doctor who'd
cured their village of yours he was
liked trusted even in a fair election he
may have won but with the all-powerful
military now putting their thumb on the
scales papadoc's path to the presidency
was sealed election day saw devalier
sweep the board netting over 72 percent
of the vote and capturing the chamber of
deputies a month later on october 22nd
the new president gave an inaugural
speech where he declared my government
will scrupulously protect the honor and
civil rights which constitute the joy of
all free peoples it was exactly the sort
of thing everybody expected to hear from
a man who'd made his career as a doctor
barely had the cheering stopped though
before devali revealed himself as lesser
patch adams and
more a dr hannibal lecter within weeks
of taking up the presidency davalier had
ordered his political opponents jailed
on spurious charges now this wasn't
super unexpected in a corrupt place like
haiti but the violence which accompanied
it was on a whole other level on
devaluing his orders the former school
teacher clermont barbo had spent the
last few months recruiting tough men as
a private paramilitary force now they
descended on those who'd stood against
devalier in 1957 they attacked them they
tortured them they purged them from
society before a year was up 300 people
had been murdered including children but
it was what came next which really
sealed papadoc's reputation around the
time of his first anniversary in power
part of the military seems to have woken
up to how bloodthirsty their so-called
puppet was vague plans were played for a
coup plans duvalier's men managed to
disrupt before they got anywhere yet the
mere threat of being overthrown was
still enough to make papadoc pivot from
his army backers to turn those thugs
barbara had recruited into his own
secret police force known as the tonton
makut they would bring terror to the
heart of haiti based on the haitian
bougie men said to stuffed children into
his ghani sack then eat them for
breakfast the tonton makut were masters
of both image and indiscriminate
violence imaged because they usually
appeared wearing shiny dark suits eye
hiding sunglasses and stylish hats
dressing like dead gangsters return to
life and violence because well just
listen to some of the atrocities that
they committed as duvalier's goons the
makut didn't just kill people they
slaughtered them burning them alive or
stoning them to death before dumping
their bodies in marketplaces as a
warning rather than pay them to bali and
barbo allowed them to make money on the
side however they wished with complete
immunity from the law the result was
violent so random that no one knew who
might be next old and young rich and
poor light-skinned and dark could all
find themselves dragged away to be
beaten tortured or murdered for sport
extortion robbery and blackmail became
just facts of life and then there was
what the makut did to women without
dwelling on the details the complete
free reign these sadistic youths had
around portu prince gave rise to a tidal
wave of sexual assault but what did
francois de valia care with his tonsil
makuu now numbering 10 000 the dictator
had already broken and he hauled the
armament bat over him from now his
hidden cruel side would be fully
unleashed and the result would be a
humanitarian tragedy
the regime took suffocating hold papadoc
began to cultivate a new personality one
that went beyond the standard dictator
model of uniformed dude in sunglasses
possibly with mustache and into
something far stranger duvalier began to
purposely model himself on baron samedi
a spirit at the graveyard's baron
samadhi is an integral part of haitian
voodoo's cosmology a trickster eternally
reminding the living of their fate but
while his role in voodoo is not to
instill fear that's exactly how papadoc
used his likeness he deliberately
dressed like the guardian of cemeteries
complete with suit top hat and cane like
the tonton makut channelling a creature
of folklore it was an intimidation
tactic but it was also a sign by
stepping into the role of a voodoo
spirit devalier was signifying his
connection to haiti's religion showing
the influential unguns that he was one
of them that they could support him not
that the freakiness of his new
personality hurt his hold on power
encouraged by the regime rumors sprang
up that the tonton makoot was zombies
papadoc had raised from the dead others
claimed he ate the hearts of his
murdered enemies and thus gained their
strengths that he could cast spells
bringing the severed heads of rebels
back to life to interrogate at leisure
as time went on there's evidence
duvalier began to believe his own hype
at one point telling associates he was
invulnerable yet when death came
knocking it wouldn't be barron's samity
that saved pappadoc's life
but uncle sam like many others during
the occupation the young doctor had
learned that the u.s was a force to be
reckoned with that no regime could
survive without washington's backing so
when he took power in 1957 duvalier made
sure to combine severe repression at
home with some good old-fashioned ass
kissing abroad casting himself as an
anti-communist bulwark papadoc wowed
washington so spectacularly that uncle
sam was soon throwing millions of
dollars at him while this allowed the
regime to consolidate its power and
embark on harebrained schemes like
trying to build a new model city named
duvalierville the real advantage came in
1959. that year devalio suffered a heart
attack that nearly killed him in another
universe perhaps it would have in this
universe though america responded by
flying in specialists to help nurse him
back to health all while the macoot
bombed newspaper officers and tortured
dissidents it took ages but finally
after enjoying the best medical support
american money could buy papadoc
returned to the presidency and at that
point he immediately went back to being
an award-winning
with devalier out of action his old
loyalist barber had become acting
president now though the rejuvenated
dictator accused his friend of planning
to supplant him and ordered him thrown
in jail for 16 months not long after he
staged a phony election despite still
having two years left in office
announced that it won 100 of the vote
and claimed an illegal second term it
was this last bit more than anything
that finally got washington to reel in
the aid that it was sending to pap a dog
but even now the c.i.a didn't try to
topple him they might no longer be
willing to fund his regime but so long
as devalier was publicly flipping the
commies of the bird the americans didn't
get a damn what he did and what the good
doctor wanted to do now was terrify even
his loyal supporters throughout his
reign papadoc relied on random cruelty
to keep people in line not just with the
opportunistic targeting of civilians by
the macutes but also by frequently
sending once-cherished aides to be
tortured for no rhyme or reason in 1963
though this repression of his supporters
reached new heights that spring clermont
barbeau now out of prison tried to get
his revenge onto valier by kidnapping
his son baby doc the ambush on the
charles sherford car killed three people
but ultimately failed rather than say
babo's thirst for vengeance it instead
sparked a blood-soaked backlash when
news reached papadoc he ordered 65 of
his own officers immediately executed in
case they were tempted to join barbo he
then ordered every black dog in the
country shot playing on a local rumor
that barbo was capable of turning into a
black dog to escape assassins finally he
had the makut corner barbo and his
followers in a sugar cane field
and set the crop on fire those who
stayed burned to death those who tried
to run were unceremoniously gunned down
it was the last time anyone in his inner
circle tried to stand up to de valier
from that day on even his closest allies
kept their heads down sadly that
wouldn't save them
as the 1970s dawned it was on a haiti
now firmly under papadoc's faux voodoo
spell back in 1964 devalier had done
what all tyrants eventually do and had
himself declared president for life what
followed had been the birth of a
personality cult so preposterous even
kim jong-un would find it tasteless with
duvalier firmly in charge the lord's
prayer was rewritten its opening line
changed to ah doc who art in the
national palace hallowed be thy name
this despite the bat connects
communicating him from the church not
that it stopped devali attending he
still went every sunday only now
surrounded by armed men just daring the
priest to throw him out then there was
the grandiose title he bestowed upon
himself one that proclaimed him
incorruptable leader of the great
majority of the haitian people renovator
of the republic chief of the revolution
and spiritual father of the nation as if
to prove his popularity villagers were
shipped in from all over the country and
made to dance outside the palace crying
his name and cheering it was an absurd
sham an entire nation mobilized to
soothe one man's fragile ego
yet behind the spectacle lay nothing but
violence and sadism in this era
teenagers who spoke against the regime
were executed with shocking regularity
close to the palace devilier began
personally leading the firing squads
that disposed of allies that he believed
had slighted him it was even said that
he had pee pulse cut into the walls of
torture chambers so that he could watch
as the tonton magoot abused their
victims the haiti the 1970s dawned on
then was an oppressive nightmarish place
a land soaked in blood it was also a
place about to undergo seismic change
ill with diabetes papadoc had always
appeared older than his age looking
frail and elderly despite being barely
60. now even as his power increased his
health began to slide in november 1970 a
second heart attack left him weaker than
before sadly though the death of the
patriarch wouldn't bring haiti relief
but only more of the same in february of
1971 de valia forced through a
constitutional change eliminating age
requirements for the presidency that
done he named his 19 year old son baby
doc his heir a dumb well-fed oath of a
playboy jean-claude valiere looked even
less of a likely president than his dad
just like his old bar though he'd cling
on to power for a long time backed by a
brutality that would have made papadoc
proud not that the older tyrant would be
around to witness it a mere two months
after sorting out his succession
francois de valliere died of heart
disease on april 21 1971 he was 64 years
old at the moment he died papadoc was
haiti's longest serving leader since
president jean-pierre boyer fled into
exile in 1843 yet what had his 13 plus
years got in his nation ninety percent
of the population was illiterate those
with means in education had all fled
resulting in a massive brain drain per
capita income was just 75 dollars per
year making haiti one of the poorest
nations on earth even divali a signature
youthful achievement had been reversed
with so much poverty around yours had
come roaring back along with a wave of
malnutrition and then were the deaths
today it's estimated between thirty
thousand and sixty thousand haitians
were murdered by the devilier regime on
top of the hundreds of thousands
tortured forced into exile or sexually
assaulted that's a total few other
tyrants in the americas could even dream
of high enough to make the devali regime
one of the deadliest scene in the
post-world war ii western hemisphere
sadly for haitians there would never be
any justice today haiti is still a
nation struggling with the after-effects
devalier's long rule the majority are
still crushed by extreme poverty a
poverty they were plunged into under
devalier which subsequent leaders have
failed to save them from in a way
perhaps this is haiti's greater tragedy
that those who came after pepper and
baby dog never managed to repair their
wounded land in many cases they never
even tried but for all haiti may suffer
a chronic lack of good leaders and the
united states that constantly intervenes
there can be no doubting who should
shoulder the most blame as leader
francois de valle brutalized his people
ruining their lives their prospects and
their economy even as he showered
himself with ever more ludicrous titles
often in these videos we try to find
some nuance in our subjects a spark of
good among even the worst a hint of
cruelty and even the greatest but there
can be no nuance when discussing papadoc
nothing else to say except that he was a
shallow callous man who did no good in
the world and far too much bad that his
legacy lives on while so many of his
victims are forgotten is nothing short
of a tragedy
[Music]
you